no but like it's it's incredible because
like i
it's the first time ever where i drank
something like a heavy heavy amount
yeah and i wake up the next morning i'm
like i i'm alive
now that's that's the thing right is
that i feel like that's a one-off right
i feel like that's being shot and it
like misses a vital organ that's what i
when you're no no no no no no no no it's
not a wonderful time for me for me like
if i just stay on wine and i just
i don't mix drinks yeah wine hangovers
are the most bearable like for me it's
like beer is like always
worth stomach always the worst headaches
suck it's like like hangover tianist
okay kangaroo
hang over tearless let's go okay so
right at the top i don't [ __ ] with this
at all
suck it yeah like yeah like so where are
we always is ester here this
the strong s tier is like the [ __ ] like
the worst hangover or shall we do the
opposite like okay it should be it
should be the opposite okay
okay well sake is like [ __ ] zed tier
okay like i remember like when uh when
chris was last on this podcast and we
went to the it's like just like just
like one shot of sakes enough to give me
a hangover yeah like
i had if i'm if i'm drinking something
else but sake has even
entered my body weight yeah it
completely contaminates me oh yeah yeah
yeah it's like [ __ ] you connor yeah i
remember
we went to the izakaya like literally
the hour afterwards
and i was on beer the entire night and
then chris was just like let's
let's get some sake right lads and we
had i had i remember having like one cup
of sake
and then i was just like gone the next
day i don't know why
i could see your brain powering down as
you drank it it's like
he had the audacity to be like this is
great it wasn't great it was [ __ ]
awful
i've had good sake that was just
slightly bearable and this [ __ ] was
awful
so is it like just going off in your
mouth like it was something just going
stale
and hit your body terrible be ashamed of
yourself yeah like the the
i've never had worse headaches in my
life after a night of just drinking sake
yeah sake is by far the worst child is
up there
just above that is like all the [ __ ]
like spirits
they're really shitty tequila's i say
tequila is the worst one yeah
i would say tequila and sambuca are like
on that level right wait a minute
i feel about like our muslim fans that
can't watch this
i wouldn't know i'll take your word for
it
because like tequila and sambuca for me
are like they're the student shots
they're they're what you get as a
student
because who drinks that all night [ __ ]
the psychopaths drinks
what even is samboo exactly you don't
know this is i don't even know it's
that's
that's that one drink that your mate is
like yeah let's get this drink and then
you have it you're like
like that what is it it's it's like a
licorice [ __ ] it's [ __ ] yeah it's it
oh is it like like jager oh i was about
okay
go go just the same level on the same
level but like going above that i would
say is jaeger right because they're
they're all they're all like
they're all the shots where you know you
wake up
and you can pinpoint the exact moment
the night went wrong
it was the exact moment someone ordered
like a round of jaeger shorts or around
sambuca shots or tequila
right for some reason melin [ __ ]
loves tequila
and i will never understand that i will
literally never understand
that what about the taste
it's good you don't like the taste so
why do you like
it
there's other alcohol
no we don't because we can't relate
because
like it tastes like us yeah and like the
first i mean look the only time
where i was like okay tequila is kind of
fun it's like the first time you do like
a
you know like the with the whole salt
thing right yeah like that's like
because that's like
the whole soul it's like playing a mini
game why are you doing
like it's like a little way i've
realized if you're like a student
which is like when you start you know
trying all these drinks yeah if you had
some kind of [ __ ] quick time event to
it
drinking becomes like 10 times more fun
yeah you're a [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah
exactly
like there was a [ __ ] in swansea when i
went to university there was this one
bar that would do these drinks with
sambuco where they would light it on
fire
yeah and then like put the like gas
chamber yeah that's what it's called
which is not a very flattering name
it's called a gas chamber which is
terrible yeah yeah and so
they would do it for like one pound 50
right which is like 2.50 i didn't know
it was legal in the uk
because i i don't know if it is but they
served it because because the only the
only time i've been able to do that is
not in the uk but it's when we go on
like [ __ ]
it might be illegal but you know how the
bars are in the uk sometimes yeah
you know you know the are you know how
some of the studio balls are it feels
like it's like world war three in some
of these bars yeah people are throwing
up everywhere they're serving drinks
people they shouldn't be
like yeah they would light the sambuca
on fire and put a wine glass over it to
extinguish the fire i've seen those yeah
and then they would put the wine glass
on the table really quickly and then you
would shot the thing
and then you have to breathe in the
fumes yeah yeah yeah wine glass yeah
yeah yeah then it would go straight to
your head
yeah like you know i've done those
before okay okay i've had sambuca
like you know you know there are you
know these like you know these like
student shops don't do it because like
even even with like tequila right you uh
you lick the salt
um do the tequila and do the lime right
yeah somehow like [ __ ] students have
found a way to make this like even more
messed up because you talk about the
kamikaze shot
did you call the kamikaze the suicide
shot yeah suicide or kamikaze
okay so instead of okay so the normal
that sounds like a jackass stunt
it is it [ __ ] is so the normal order
you go in is that you lick the salt you
do the tequila shot and then you
suck on the stamina
so okay how about this how about instead
of licking the salt
you snort the stalks that sounds stupid
and then
you take the shot and instead of sucking
on the lime you just
put it in your eyes yeah who the [ __ ]
thought of this so
i'm thinking about a new challenge it's
the [ __ ] yourself in public challenge
just [ __ ] yourself on the train and just
see how long i had a friend of my 18th
birthday who did
that three times why because because we
were playing darts and he was like he
was so [ __ ] cocky about it he was
like
i'll beat you like i practice every
[ __ ] day and i'm like
you're like seven shots in like you're
not gonna [ __ ] beat me so you're
watching i totally understand people
like i don't want drinks when i want to
hear about this [ __ ] i'm like why aren't
you oh no absolutely
yeah we don't need courage this is this
has always been
a [ __ ] step level behind me people
who did like vodka shots through their
eyeball
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
like what's wrong with people
what the [ __ ] you have a perfectly
functioning mouth
just use it like i like i like for me i
feel old whenever you know like
maybe i've always been old because like
any time i've heard like a story
story like that i'm just like who the
[ __ ] thinks this is cool do you have
brain damage
it's it's it's like what went on what
went wrong in your life to think that
doing a vodka shot in your eye was
badass right because this is why this is
the aspect i hated about being in
university is that like
they would be like yeah so you do the
vodka shot in your eye and i'm like why
and then they'd be like oh cause it gets
you drunk quicker i'm like this
literally
takes five minutes yeah just drink it
like and then and then i'm the [ __ ]
weirdo out of the group because i'm the
one
who doesn't want to shop yeah yeah he's
like the [ __ ]
yeah next thing you know they'll be like
yeah i took like some [ __ ] ethanol
and i [ __ ] just injected into my
veins
it was [ __ ] rock and roll man that
was metal as [ __ ] and i'm just like
i can't at what point do we acknowledge
that this is just stupid [ __ ]
i don't want to be someone who's done a
shoei a couple of times in your life
like i can't i can't really say anything
unfortunately
so that that's just that's probably the
most [ __ ] up one i've done yeah
how the [ __ ] did we get on this topic i
don't know what we did we didn't address
the the wine to
the hangover tea list by the way i'll
just do it for you right now is number
one wine is second b is in the middle
and then all the other weird spirits are
down below and then
right at the bottom of sake there you go
boom so you say we did not finish that
tangent [ __ ] you
yes what's the next topic
it wasn't an extension